going to talk about middle game and I
prepared
one of my recent games I played an
American Open tournament it's over
Thanksgiving so I did well this year in
that tournament finished first place and
this game it's like when opponent plays
a little bit inaccurate in the opening
and then that leads to a middle game
position where his piece a little bit
awkward a place and then you very
energetically take advantage of it so
this is what this game will demonstrate
to you here so d4 my opponent is
unblocked in this game
my opponent international master which I
think 2gm norms is kitten
kevrah there's a good player plays a lot
of chess a lot of tournaments he's
trying to get his final GM GM norm so d4
are I played Knight f6 and get them
plate Knight f3 so I played a 6e he
knows you know isn't you knows his
theory and he likes to play this Bishop
g5 kind of call a in a London type of
positions where he you know put the
pants on he 3 c3 it's very solid it's
hard to break through so when I saw this
I wasn't very excited in the beginning I
thought it would be kind of a very slow
manoeuvring game but I played what I
usually play in this position just to be
6 it should be 7 this is how I like to
develop then I put the pawn on c5 and
just get you know get all the pieces are
Bishop e7 Castle just just the general
plan here in this kind of position so if
you don't know what to do against call
it system this is a good system you know
with the plant like this I'll just make
some moves you see Bishop d7 then you
play see five Bishop Bishop e7 and then
you castle and then it depends what
opponent does but you can actually make
an exchange on D force
and then play d69 bd7 so this is a
interesting setup so you just show you
for example this is not a game but so
you have a better better idea so let's
say if light white plays this ultra
solid ultra solid setup here right so
you take takes you play d6 just the
general perspective night goes on d7
they play Queen e2 you play a six they
play a four so you play rook e8 okay
it's very important you put the rook
only eight then this because you can use
the F eight squared for one of your
pieces you can go Bishop f8 if you need
to Knight f8 at some point you put the
Queen on c7 and slowly you're preparing
b5 break at a at the right time
on the other hand white also doesn't
have that many useful moves in this
position so you can also play h6 later
so the difference here is like it's you
don't allow him to play 95 ever so I
call it players they like you when you
put the pawn on d5 they can jump in on
if I with the night and they play effort
to cement the position of the night -
and that's what they like to do but with
this setup you don't allow that and
there was some really good games played
you know by many good players you should
look at the game I can just remember a
few of them on top of my head you can
look at the game between Kamsky playing
white against magnus carlsen world
champion and you know world champion won
quite convincingly this game also a game
by Vietnamese super Grandmaster like one
liam he played very well also the system
so got some nice wins so yeah and just
black is already equal here of course
white is not worse but he doesn't really
have a clear plan and at the right time
maybe you can play Bishop be c6 and
slowly play b5 before you don't have any
any problems here so it's very
comfortable and a good setup actually
for for black so this is what I was
going to do
against kitten if you had played that
but he he played the he surprised me
here I mean II for is a one of the main
moves here and then if h6 Bishop takes
the six Queen f6 play but Keaton took on
f6 after the game he told me this was
his preparation for another player that
he played the point is he wants to play
e4 right away but he's giving up the
bishop very early without me playing h6
so that's actually very important nuance
in this position actually preserved a
move because I never played h6 usually
I'm happy to play tricks to get the
bishop but if he's going to give me the
bishop like this it's it's great so I
think maybe it wasn't a very good idea
to play like this we play E for you
should be seven we should do two so from
here on now from here on I want you to
think about it and see what you can try
to do here to try to actually I think
yeah he played then see Bishop d7 yeah
he played nobility to here first because
he was perhaps worried about some
possibilities like Queen g6 doing double
attack on this two pounds so if they
deny BD to and from here on I'd like you
to take control of this game and find
all the moves here until I want it was
not that many moves actually it just
happened to be a quiet quite nice and
easy win for me but let's see if you can
find the rest of the moves of this game
so he did play a little bit dubious with
this capture Bishop g5 Bishop f6 but
what are you going to do here what
you're going to do to use your two
bishops because if you don't do anything
special he will play Bishop e2 then he
will play castle and nothing really will
happen so that's why you have to try to
do something so black to play here
please raise your hand if you have an
idea here how I should try to proceed
to gain the advantage here at the moment
I already realize that I should play for
advantage here not just to equalize the
game yes excellent idea
the reason c5 is good because it will
allow us to open up some diagonals for
our bishops when you have two bishops
you want to do what open up the game
right open the position and that's
exactly what c5 is accomplishing you
cannot play d5 because that just lose
upon he 5 I just go Queen g6 if you
place it let's see 3 actually if it
takes on c5 I just go Bishop c5 and I'm
comfortable now he played c3 now what
are you going to do now
correct decision yes you want to open
the position the best way to do it is
make a couple of exchanges and that way
you will open up the position now if he
takes with a pawn actually after 96 is
actually quite awkward for him because
how can you protect this weak pawn on d4
if he goes Knight b3 then we should be
for check so it's really really awkward
now this position for him if you place a
5 I'll just go clean g6 and I also have
94 ideas so that didn't work so it took
9 takes default and now
absolutely Bishop c5 excellent choice
and actually do you know that now
black-white has only one move here not
to lose pawn because it's kind of
awkward now his center so he has to make
the only move not to lose any material
and I'm gaining more temples remember
that's very important in opening to gain
those temples so what is the only move
for white now yes
Oh Queen a4 yeah but Queen effort is not
good a six and B 500 yeah yes Queen f3
bishop before we lose upon take take
Wendy 4 so the only move is actually the
awkward looking nice for to f3 so now he
moved his knight twice the position is
getting semi open and I've got my two
bishops excellently lined up see this
when you have bishop sizes you don't
need to worry about anything you you got
you got good control here okay now a
very interesting decision here needs to
be made of course you can play a normal
move like ninety six which probably is a
very decent move but I wanted to play a
little bit put some more pressure on him
here so yes d5 d5 you could but you
don't want to do that because that
allows a very powerful Bishop if I check
and your King gets cut in the middle of
the board do not open the position when
your king is open when your king is in
the middle of the board do not open the
position especially if opponent can
develop his bishop with the check okay
so remember that so don't do that
and don't you know that's your cavalry
now the d7 pawn is covering your King
you don't open it right now later when
you're better develop you can consider
doing that now what did I play here huh
about g'bye absolutely correct g5 that's
a very powerful move by my comer
excellent yes
bravo Bravo Mike this is a this is a
actually it's not like I play this move
that's why I say but this is a quiet
quite a nice move actually it shows that
quite a good understanding of positional
chess because you're fighting for dark
squares here and not only immediately
you're trying to play gg for this
immediate threat as well but it's it's
gaining space and forcing opponent to
make another concession which is h3 to
stop G for now but then you don't just
now you pause you already weakened the
position okay so you don't don't
immediately assume when you play a g5
your next move should be
h5 a lot of people believe that when you
start pushing you have to push but no
this was the set a purpose of creating
some dark square weaknesses and now
what's the logical thing to do what
would be the logical response here
yes absolutely absolutely sometimes you
know these simple moves are your best
moves most of the time actually you know
most of the time simple moves you know
developing excellent move now I think by
now Keaton was not happy about his
position here things are not looking
good I mean there's no safe place for
his king huge because h5 g4 is coming
Castle queenside problematic f2 is
hanging so this is an example where
opening went wrong so he tried to make
some drastic ideas you know 94 trying to
play some concrete chess he wants to get
one of my bishops basically and if he
gets one of my bishops then he maybe
it's a little bit safe White's position
is still kind of safe now let's see if
we can find the following move here
because he wants to put that night on d6
it's also possible that the following
move he might have underestimated it
okay because that's a very powerful idea
don't rush think this is not a very
simple idea here
Queen effort is possible but he will go
Bishop d3 or something like that and
then then play g3 I'm not sure what is
the idea here what is that the you know
powerful idea here as if you don't play
this move you don't have that much of an
advantage but after a following oh you
have a serious advantage Queen a4 is a
decent move decent alternative
absolutely correct decision Bravo but I
would then yet defy very strong move
attacking the knight he has to react
correct if it pushes it's not good you
know you can play point f4 and then you
win the e5 pawn 496 you take twice so
this is he talk and now what's the
follow-up here Castle Queen this is the
moment that I played actually and I
played it very proudly not thinking that
I play the best move because it just
felt absolutely right and of course
after the game I analyzed and computers
suggested just this was just much
stronger again the line that the
computer gives it's like it's very
difficult to calculate but apparently
after take there is Oh apparently
there's this check here which I did not
see it's a special check and if it goes
here now night before and apparently now
Queen d8 he has struck d8 and I'm
winning exchange I'm not winning the
game here but I'm winning exchange he
will have a pawn but I am better facing
basically I did not see Queen e7 so and
immediately I calculated immediate night
before doesn't quite work because he
takes on my bishop so this was nice in
between with check and night before but
anyway I was happy with my move it's
maybe the second move
second best move but it's still a very
good move now I'm ready to take now
Andrew kg8 and play d4 completely open
the position and win this game so his
next move was the only move he could
play to avoid losing immediately push
the six now he push these six trying to
close the position
now what you're going to do here you can
really take the palm back because the
night is there and you will likely win
this pawn here but at the moment you
should not focus on that this expand too
much you should focus on what you can
really try to do here to improve your
position
so this is basically already at the
opening part completely finished you
were in the middle game where every move
it's like finding a plan if you have a
plan you always should have a plan you
should never make a move without having
a plan even if it's mainly not the best
plan but just have an idea something
that you're aiming for here every move
should create a threat some old threat
perhaps yes absolutely correct this is
the time to do it this is a time to
renew the threat of G for now we are
threatening to play G for to move that
night and win on f2 now
you mean b5 when
aha now if I go here with which piece
okay I take your palm there's this one
problem there but we'll go with that
problem now the problem is here Queenie
- next move and then ninety four is
coming so we're losing a pun here
and I'm not sure I think we might have
some compensation but I'm not sure if
it's sufficient because next one is
Queenie - and then you can run away you
know might not be sufficient we have
another participant suggested this move
here do you see the reputation of this
move Knight takes B six discovery check
C refutation is - using the pawn again
okay I don't put your pieces on loose
squares when you put your pieces on
loose squares they become a target okay
so in general not even the Queen b6 e
even if he didn't have that he could
have played Queen a4 and then your
pieces becoming loose pieces okay so
that's why you don't want to create
loose pieces so h5 see everything is
guarded now again put pressure more
pressure more chances to opponent to go
wrong put pressure on the opponent and
that way he can make a mistake
well this position is already bad so he
played Queen e2 now he protects f2 so if
I play g4 he will just go 90 to 90 for
putting his knight on a good square that
will be an excellent you know transfer
of the night - but that's not what I'm
going to do now I should just play sim
you should play simple now okay don't
again III play with the intention okay I
play with the intention of g4 but then I
see he's going to go huge and then he's
going to go here then I say okay let's
change the plan now
pause a little bit pass on that one now
which would I play in this position
better if I was an idea but he's going
to go long castle and that's it
and he's an escape from the danger don't
allow him to do that yet
Queen h6 then he goes Knight FD - and
then maybe try to bring the knight only
four or be three and just again castle
and run away from the danger
when you look at the position and the
concrete ideas don't work always look at
possibility of grabbing the material
okay if concrete ideas don't work you
take the material okay especially if
that material is in front of you
blocking your pieces okay absolutely
take on these six now open up that line
right for the rook it's in front of you
it's blocking causing problems right
take it away now he's got to take the
bishop bishop is very powerful so he's
happy at least he achieved a very small
plaster but the problem here remains
still now King is stuck in the middle of
the boat he can't hustle and lack of
development now I have much better
development but he's trying to catch up
he goes Queen III now putting pressure
on this pawn and now it looks like I
might need to somehow defend this pawn
if I push the pawn I didn't like Queen
g5 he's forcing an endgame and and I'm
not sure if I'm even better or maybe I'm
a little better but not so clear so here
I started to think I knew that I have
something you know I had ideas in a
rakta fight maybe or something then I
realize maybe I don't need to protect
this pawn and here where I stood this
beautiful combination would actually
occurred you know usually you see some
beautiful ideas but it never works
because your opponent sees it also but
this time I got lucky he missed the idea
and this turned out to be a very nice
game like it's almost a masterpiece
tactical look now what to do
before it's a but immediately it doesn't
quite work because he just takes it and
then when you take on b2 right then it
goes Quincy one check and swaps the
Quinns so that's a that's a that's a
good idea to look at it but you need
some more build-up before that idea will
work what did I play here huh what did I
try to do with which idea did I see here
in advance that I can try to conduct
here yes
sacrifice the palm tree very confident
with it is that you find someone got
great we he takes this is what happened
but he confidently took here but this
was a blunder now he should have done
something else but his position is bad
they should be too
bishop eat Bishop e2 Bishop e2 I play
rock d5 and then I have this g4 threat
again and it's quite awkward for him
buck is much better but he took now what
do you
what to do here huh yeah but you're
dropping another pawn here on f7 after
that it's not that great for us again
you need to be tactically sharp here
because this is an opportunity now here
this is a very once very rare
opportunity to win a game very rare
opportunity here to make a move like
this see my queen is under attack yeah
it seems like I got to move the Queen or
exchange it what else to do
checkmate would be nice but in order to
do that we have to find something else
something else to create weaknesses in
his camp Knight neither did you
calculate it
but I will Bravo Danny yes see don't be
too attached to your Quinn sometimes you
can sacrifice it when you see a mate
well he took because what else you can
do by the way if he goes back on c1
actually I was actually looking at this
I just play 93 and take route d3 his
position is defenseless because f3 is is
gone and - king will be mated so this is
bad bad bad so he plays day he takes he
saw this but he missed one sequence
where you know that I can't take on b2
here again I can't because of this Queen
c1 check so what can I do now that's
what he was expecting this is what he
was anticipating okay but then check
then he see check no it's not over yet
it's not over yet I have to find the
superb move for white here otherwise I'm
winning he can't take roopd one check it
looks like the game is over here he's
gonna get mated but there is a move
there is a very nice strong move he has
here hidden yes Queen g3 again pin it
and now a four minute here and I can't
move my look unbelievable and
unbelievable here takes and he runs away
and he's a happy person but when you
sense that there is something wrong in
this position right you gotta turn on
your tactical alertness here okay
to find to do things with the forcing
way okay the forcing way so he cannot
escape so what is the idea here
yes
okaythat's check Bravo Bravo check
he takes check again
he takes check again oh yeah yeah yeah
that's I win the Queen egg check check
check remember check check check check
capture check always look at checks
checks first remember now we reach the
following position here he gives me a
check
it is winning but still you have to play
precise precision okay so where do I go
with the King here where do I go with
this King here yes yeah okay where to go
to try to control the squares of the
bishop and maybe you have some really
cool ideas later on
Bravo Nagas kinky - trying to bring his
look finally into the game and he wants
to set up some kind of fortress with b5
we don't want to allow that we don't
want to allow him to play b5 and put
some kind of fortress okay at least it's
a fortress on the queenside
maybe he won't be able to hold it but we
don't want that now you can force the
resignation in two more moves two more
moves you can which move is necessary
yes not yet include something first
so his roof doesn't come into the game
of course check on e5 now you want to
take this with the check as well so he
has to go to f1 to stay in this area and
now if you tip that will be a mistake
you place b5 and then you'll have some
problems winning that position you might
be able to win it but you don't want
that you don't want that trouble okay so
which move you're going to play to avoid
that problem of course palm b5 and now
you're resigned here because the next
one is king b6 like let's say he plays
rook g1 just king b6 here okay I can
just go ahead and we know it's pants or
I can drop his bishop like this attack
okay going over here attack the bishop
is trapped it should be trapped the game
is over so after I played b5 it's
completely hopeless my opponent resigned
so and this was a good way and it helped
me to win the tournament
it wasn't the the strongest tournament
but it was still you know there were
several gun masters so it was a good
tournament very popular installed in
California you know about 200
participants so American Open 2015 ok
any questions about this game very good
I have one we have a little bit more
time so I want to set up a couple of
positions for you how many play
are familiar with this endgame please
raise your hand this is very famous
endgame position if you know it that's
very good
do you know the name of it no okay not
everybody raise their hands with one or
two people so that means this would be a
very useful example for us white to play
and draw believe it or not down upon
you're going to be able to accomplish a
draw here and the only way to do it here
is to find that only move I cannot tell
you the name for it because you find it
immediately ah king of two actually he
has the opposition because your King has
to move so it doesn't quite work here
okay doesn't quite work here so which
move is it and why yes one yes and if it
goes up there I go up and I go here all
day I don't know because your pawn is on
the way we can't unfortunately we come
to a stop here because your pawn is
obstructing you and that means you go
this way I get the opposition you go
this way I get the opposition you go
here I get behind upon and push you away
from your pawn push you with my king
okay so you go here I come up and then I
push you back that's it now you take I
take and just touch down okay so
so which move is going to help white
twoa come if you do make a draw what is
the idea what is it called
distant opposition yes so remember if
you're not familiar with this term it's
the opposition but there is more
distance so they call distant opposition
here okay distant opposition here here
here here okay
go here and here
distant remember distant opposition and
now whatever he does you just get the
opposition to him okay now last chance
he is going to toss this pawn in with g4
to see if he can complicate the position
to win this huh very good don't take
because in the race you lose the race
right because he says check and goes
back and wins the pawn so very good idea
where you move the King G to Bravo
and now if it takes you take with the
king you come up and you wind upon now
last chance yesh last moment here here
you have to make sure you go correctly
here as well now
kingi 3r and I take uh and who has the
opposition bloc has the opposition okay
so don't rush don't play King g3 here
yet what you're going to do is take the
pawn of course because he's no longer
quitting with the check push push
now you would right good let me you make
a job okay so that's the only way you
can do this okay by playing a move like
King h1 if you had not known this idea I
can you know I'm pretty sure you're not
going to play King h1 if you don't know
what distant opposition is okay or how
the distant opposition works okay so now
today you'll learn another idea in
endgame that you can use in the King and
pawn end games you use the idea called
distant opposition any questions about
the opposition okay very good
and I will do one study now for your end
game study okay so you can solve this
one okay white to play and win looks
kind of complicated I mean we're trying
to make this King but it's not so simple
yes 92
move forward like that well you looked
at this probably yeah yeah yeah that
would have been a little bit too simple
enough for this class a little bit too
simple a little bit too simple that
would have been a pretty straightforward
checkmate in three yeah correct
again if I had gone here same crowd
check and okay for meit this is the
moment before the king he escapes on the
tree you must make this move because
otherwise he simply escapes it and if
you play a move like this actually still
made well he had other ideas stupid so
so you don't look at rook t4 you will
remember this idea for a long time once
you find it it's spectacular
it's spectacular move next
yes
trick
who has it one student is okay what's
the move
correct Alex Bravo Bravo
yes excellent move now he cannot take
with his King because he have a fork so
yes take back with the Queen and then
what they do nice look at that it's a
step away thank you very much
Bravo yes yes that's for next lesson
next lesson when we have an endgame
lesson I teach you that now Queen g8
looks like I stopped it up no looks like
I stopped our idea
now what are you gonna do
check beautiful no it takes very good
like I say I promise to show you this
you know if you don't know how to do it
one of the upcoming classes on the
endgame team okay so you're not going to
get this too often I only had it once
and I've been playing for a little very
long time so it's not the most common
but you should know how to win this the
main idea it's called W maneuver there
are three stages here you know to win
this first you force the King to the
corner then actually two stages you
force take into the corner using your
paces then you use the W maneuver to get
him to the right color corner dark like
here will be dark color here so it would
make him on here on here and then just
check made them okay okay thank you
everyone for attending the class
you